今日は1週間ぶりに静岡に帰って来ましたはじめ社長です今日も動画ですね
はじめしゃちょーあのアニメで帰ったらどうなるのでたまにツイッターとかで見たこと
あると思うんですけどもある人物とか姉御キャラクターを別のアニメの風に変えたら
何何風とかあるじゃないですかワンピース風に変えたとかドラゴンボー
いうふうに帰ったとか絶対ありえない作画で書きませみたいですが流行ってたと思うん
ですけども
それ俺
カンナを持って今回ですね何種類かのアニメの作画風に始めるぞ書いてもらいました
ありがとうございます
今後でたちまた計算とイラストレーターさんにお願いして肇社長
そのアニメ組んで書いたらどうなるのっていうのを書いていただきました本当に
ありがとうございますアニメて結構その作画に特徴があるのが多かったんで
俺意外とキャラ薄いんですよねー長いいろんなユーチューバー言いますけど結構はじめ
した鳥って
[拍手]
特徴ないんですよ
自分で言ったようなんですよ機構特徴ない4なんでそれをいかに一家にアニメ風に変え
て頂けているかと言うとすごい気になってるのでさっそく見て行きたいと思います
ではまず超王道のところからいきましょうかドラえもんむふドライ毛布中でも2つを見
ていきたいとおもいます
こちらです
おおおお
をやっほぉは確かにドラえもんっぽいマナーいますねちょっとでもなんか左官名が
ラリってる気もしますが
のび太くんのかジャイアンとかそういうタイプじゃなくちょっとインテリ系のね出来杉
君の方向の人間なんでしょうねやっぱりわかりやすく白釉来てシュライブを好きって
おりますいいですねちょっと知的な感じありますね目がちょっとやっぱ
やはりいっ
なりんじゃないと思いますけど特徴的ですねなんか昔国へディアスならなかった時も
あるんでだけその数ですねえいう音インテリ計画でて4救急きぱなものなのと
ドラえもんとにかくとぼけこんな感じになりますねでは続いて会員次回地風に変えて
もらいましょうか
どうなったんですよ結構特装的なので花とが多分キュッてなってる気がしますこちらで
far
バッハ
馬やっぱ now 種ってなってるんだなあああああなるほどなるほど
すごいなぁちゃんと返っハイジっぽいで目指すプーんすいません
かいじゅう見たことないんですよ
続いて醸造で上場ねジョジョもな考えかさの作画が濃いと言いますか特徴的なんです
けどもうさせて肇社長如像バズをどうなってるんでしょうか
こちらへ御ヌゲー
かっこいい
えっめっちゃかっこいいおく方はだけピアスて言ってるんですけどそれもしっかり支え
て頂いておりますね
あこれはれた最近のオレっぽいの結構ねっ
めっちゃ気入りますジョジョすごい
見たことないけどじゃあさをちょっと見たことない俺なんか座のあついあついあの良い
意味でちょっと暑い作画の映画ちょっとですねなかなかとっつきにくいと言いますか
ちょっとなんか見てないんですよね王道系のアニメあんまり見てないんですよただ
ジョジョの酒がとかの感じは分かるんではめっちゃくちゃズっぽいなっていうのは
わかります
youtube の再生ボタンも走っておりますしいやースゴイねこれなーあーなんか
急にガッと来ましたね素晴らしいですありがとうございますございますかっこいい
さぁ続いてはドラゴンボールでございますあぁ私ドラゴンボール大好きです聞くほど
大好きです実家で塔体が漫画全巻集めてたから4なんですけど多分これを大
そうじゃないんですけどボールなぜたのとうちゃんが手マンが連れてなかったロケット
のドラゴンボールだけ読んでなかったと思うんですけどほんとよかった人の1ボール
dragon ball kai も全部見たんでもうかなり好きな作品の類に入る
ドラゴンボールの策がこちらになります
どうぞ
をラルーなるほどですね
ポタラポタが付けれな髪の毛が経ってないタイプのスーパーサイズですね
スーパーサイヤ人で髪の毛が金髪になるだけじゃなくてその逆だっちゃう怒りで髪の毛
がですがこれって逆立ってないので多分祭神の月下旬のハーフとかクォーターとそう
いう類なんで悟天とトランクスのスーパー歳児パッドなれたんでしょ
とすればスーパーサイズになりやすいのかもしれないんですけども決して強そうでは
ない
やっぱちょっと字細さがでちゃってますね体に神の細さがちゃんと面に件って書いて
ありますが凄い凄いスーパーでございましたよ
確かにでも出始め社長かを残すんだったら髪の毛坂だ2だけにもいきませんし
でもうすごいなぁなんてば特徴とらえてますねちゃんとスペリオレっぽさは出てると
思う
今村とありがとうございますああこれね俺が小沢 the
注文したんですよこれお願いしますってあのメイドインアビス
メイドイン amis あのご存じでしょうか映画化もされてるんで知ってる方も多い
けど知らない方もいるような気もしますけど
かわいらしい子どもたちが地下に傍系新宿話なんですけどもアニメの内容めちゃくちゃ
グロいのに絵がすごいかわいいんですよ
ちょっとそそられたか
小ちょっと気になった方ぜひ見てみてください made in アビス風に髪3冊を
書くとこんな感じでございますどうぞ
運命運営これ売っちゃメイドいやビスっぽい
メイドやビス見た人ならわかると思いますがメッチャうまいなこれ
レフっていうキャラクターがいるんですけどロボットの恵みがちゃんとあるんだけど
めっちゃ可愛いところぞあの着ぐるみてるし
まあ
んあっ合えばうこれは嬉しいは b 問屋人めちゃくちゃいいが可愛いんですよこう
いう感じのとばっかり出てくるんですけど結構グロい入ってるこのへの立ってる気に
なった方はぜひ見てみてくださいさあそれでは1ペースでございますワンピースあ
健康へがわかりやすい中間なんかこの目がガッと見開いてると言いますかはつらつとし
た感じの絵のイメージがありますワンピース
始めたそう見ていきましょうこちら
無事家に帰るいいですいや内海これもうこれワンピって君のはじめしたぞというか
ルフィーですねやっぱ主人公みたいな感じで書いていたら
ギターんでしょうか確かになんか特徴部分的には肇社長っぽいかけてますねピアソン
だってありますし
なんかアホの人か9とかもねちょっとれるより細くなくている気がしますね
ただこれはルギーですねマイナーも甘すぎてもうローズフィーでしか見えないよ
さぁ続いてはですね決めつの刃でございますさあもうすぐいう萼片が始まるということ
では加えせるんですけども決めつの刃もね結構真の提出ととかがあるイメージなんで
風なのかな例えば防止キャラは丹次郎ですがメディア素が初めて時光苗場バード
どうぞ全然ないかい全員税内海これ
[音楽]
ですコーナンで全員杖や9回けど服がちゃんと youtube の再生バックになっ
てるの
アンジェロでもないして全員ざーでも確かになんかぽい息をしますね宇津木な部分とか
ありますし
アンチのポイ捨てでもなんか確かに水の呼吸というより雷の呼吸の感じがあります県
からは初めという文字がちらっと見えております
できレスありがとう
ございますうまぁ上手いけどこれはもう全5ですね
スポーツですありがとうございますさあ良いは最後でございます最後は東京
リベンジャーズもう
しちゃ笑顔最近行っておりますし漫画ももういざ薬全部読んでおりますねもう本当に
いいよ俺不良なんだとがあんまり好きじゃないんですよ
怖いし魔ゼルな規犬不良とタイプいるものは
てたというもう本当にキャラとかも素敵なアニメでございます東京リベンジは果たして
弾み社長は
等距離便雑どのポジションなのでしょうかいきますこちらだ
[音楽]
はいっ
おおーー
なるほどなるほどマイ君がありますねぇ
多分方のここも初めて書いてあるんでしょうね
いいねなんか髪型もちゃんとオレっぽいと言いますかこういうなんか止めたりするん
ですよ
たまにまあ嬉しいなあこれは何か真面目東京リベンジャーズ見てるとなんかまっすぐの
不良にもなってみたかったなっていう思いがちょっと
芽生えちゃうよねやー素敵ですありがとうございますありがとうございますこれ一人で
書いたのかのこんないろんな先が一人でかける
やばいよこのひとまずで素敵なアニメ風イラスト本当にありがとうございました
個人的には仗助とエイド in 亜美さんマジ特徴掴んでるだと言いますかいそうな
感じがめちゃくちゃ嬉しかったです
他のもいるんですけどやメールを止めたこれすごいやまずで俺これさぁ
アイコンにしようかなラインのこんなあの毒そうだね男をここまで初めにしていただき
いましたありがとうございますはいアニメん月みたいな感じになってますけども僕ワン
ピース見たことないんですよ
もう徐々になるとも開示もバーンピースを見たことないんですね結構ほんとなんか王道
系があんまり夢見る気になれなくて
ええええ
見ます
re dl
[音楽]